The answer is this is the largest covariance. It's the widest spread.
This is the smallest, and this is medium.
To see how this is being found in the formula over here,
the difference between x and y is being normalized by the covariance.
The larger this value, the less the difference over here matters,
and, as a result, the more the function is spread out.
So functions with a very wide spread have the largest covariance,
whereas functions with small spread have the smallest covariance.
Put differently, the sigma-squared covariance is a measure of uncertainty.
The larger sigma-squared, the more uncertain we are about the actual state.
This is a very certain distribution where expected deviation is small.
This is a relative uncertain distribution where we know very little.